[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I think I'd like to go
back home ♪
♪ And take it easy ♪
♪ There's a woman
that I'd like to get to know ♪
♪ Living there ♪
♪♪
♪ Everybody seems to wonder ♪
♪ What it's like down here ♪
♪ Gotta get away from this
day-to-day running around ♪
♪ Everybody knows
this is nowhere ♪
-♪ La-la-la, la-la-la-la ♪
-♪ Everybody, everybody knows ♪
♪♪
-♪ Every time I think
about back home ♪
♪ It's cool and breezy ♪
♪ I wish that I could be there
right now ♪
♪ Passing time ♪
♪♪
♪ Everybody seems to wonder ♪
♪ What it's like down here ♪
♪♪
♪ Gotta get away from this
day-to-day running around ♪
♪ Everybody knows
this is nowhere ♪
-♪ La-la-la, la-la-la-la ♪
-♪ Everybody, everybody knows ♪
♪♪
-♪ Never thought love
had a rainbow on it ♪
♪ Used to think a cloud
was a nightmare ♪
♪ That was up until
when I first met you ♪
♪ Now I go around
hoping you care ♪
♪ Dance, dance,
feel it all around you ♪
♪ Dance, dance, dance ♪
♪ Never thought love
had a rainbow on it ♪
♪ See the girl dance ♪
♪♪
-Whoo!
-♪ Mississippi mud
never touched her fingers ♪
♪ California sand
lies in her hand ♪
♪ Love her more than life
as the daylight lingers ♪
♪ Early in the morning,
I'll be her man ♪
♪ Dance, dance,
feel it all around you ♪
♪ Dance, dance, dance ♪
♪ Mississippi mud
never touched her fingers ♪
♪ See the girl dance ♪
♪♪
-Whoo!
♪ See the girl dance ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]